OMG we can't believe it
but yeah Adele really disappeared Into
Thin Air on opening night of her
long-awaited Vegas residency weekends
with Adele
[Music]
after postponing the show in January the
singer delivered a show full of
unexpected moments like this magical
Vanishing stunt
well hang on a minute but there's more
check out this illusion Adele's piano
melting away during what else Set Fire
to the Rain
[Music]
and looks like Adele is keeping up with
Tick-Tock Trends because we finally got
to see this viral choreo courtesy of
Megan the stallion demonstrated by Adele
herself well kinda
[Music]
feel safe to say Adele kicked things off
in Sin City with a bang a complete
Whirlwind but it's like so much fun as
well and the performance Drew in tons of
fans including Adele's close pal stormzy
who told E.T last week he'd be there
opening weekend you know I I as as
anyone knows I think that from before I
even knew her
I'm I was a I stood onto this day a
massive fan you know I mean and I think
everyone just knows that um the woman
that they see is as remarkable as she is
in real life as they see on the screen
you know I mean so I said dear friend of
mine for stormzy and fans across the
globe weekends with the Dell has been a
long time coming back in January just
hours before opening night Adele made
this tearful video announcing she needed
to postpone the show I'm so sorry but um
my show ain't ready we're going to
reschedule all of the dates and I'm
going to finish my show
and I'm going to get it to where it's
supposed to be Adele has very exacting
specifications she's very particular
about how she presents herself and how
she wants the show to go so is that an
artist being an artist is that a diva
being a diva is that her team uh making
these demands hard to say but it's there
are a lot of potential stumbling blocks
I'm a control freak and and I get really
anal about things flash forward to
November seems Adele did the most with
her extra time and delivered a show full
of magic touches
foreign